let's talk about Jill Stein as most of
you know I've been saying that Jill
Stein's campaign stunk from the get-go
and every time I say it people get mad
people cancel memberships people send me
angry messages but you know that I don't
sugarcoat my views on the show if I'm
going to say something that will anger
people I'm okay with that as long as
it's what I actually believe and that
has been sort of the guiding principle
on the show the latest with Jill Stein
is that there seems to be something
really weird going on with those
millions of dollars that Jill Stein
raised to pay for a recount of the 2016
presidential election in some key swing
states and from the beginning I was
asking number one from a legal
standpoint can Jill Stein demand or
trigger a recount for elections that she
definitely didn't win in other words
does she have standing to request or
demand or force a recount in a state
where either Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton won I don't know what the answer
was to that but it ended up being merely
academic because it never moved forward
and from day one it stunk to high heaven
that Jill Stein after appearing at an
event in Russia with Michael Flynn and
Vladimir Putin immediately dismissed the
possibility that Russia made any
attempts to influence the 2016 election
but immediately started raising millions
of dollars for these nebulous recounts
that it wasn't even clear whether she
could get started because of standing
issues but she raised seven million
dollars from people who wanted the
recounts in those few states it has been
about a year and a half the stein
campaign has not filed an FEC report
since September of 2017 it's been almost
a year and the campaign said about a
month and a half ago that they have only
nine hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars in recount funds left where did
the other six million dollars go how did
Jill Stein and her campaign spend six
million dollars in 16 months and why did
they stop filing reports about that
spending and The Daily Beast reached out
to Jill Stein's attorney jonathan Abadi
who said well you know the recount
effort is continuing first of all I want
to know what specific realistic
recount efforts are underway how is the
money being spent for furthering those
recount efforts
Jill Stein's campaign spokesperson says
that there still could be a recount and
that the stein campaign is also bringing
another challenge regarding inspecting
voting software that was used in some
states I'm having a very hard time
believing that any of this stuff is
actually going to happen and bigger
picture we need her campaign held
accountable for not reporting their
spending right the FEC has already
warned Jill Stein about about this there
has been a half a year of spending
unaccounted for that the FEC wrote to
her about in May and then of course this
goes fundamentally to Jill Stein's
honesty or lack thereof her campaign
made the promise that any leftover money
the roughly one hundred and sixty one
thousand donors who donated would get to
decide how the money is used not only
has that not happened 6/7 of the money
is gone six million of the seven million
dollars is gone without a single recount
and without actually being accounted for
and I'm not patting myself on the back I
and many others warned people about
donating Curt I can Walled warned people
about donating Jill Stein has been
refusing to cooperate with the Russia
investigation she has not filed the
appropriate reports about the spending
I'm not surprised at all by this yeah I
mean it's all a little bit hard to
believe that they just took the money
and ran though because this was all done
in public right they were asking for a
recount money you know I out in the
public square so that would be quite
brazen to do don't you think I mean it's
not like they're doing some underground
secretive thing where they're trying to
come up with some ponzi scheme here we
don't know what they're doing right we
don't know what they're doing because
six million has been spent and they
haven't filed any spending reports in
September and we don't know what's going
on with the recounts which they simply
claim are continuing it's almost the
next election right it's almost November
of 2018 now if you don't like the story
if you don't like me doing this story
don't tell me I'm a democratic shill
because I'm not don't tell me I'm a
Russia bot and I don't mean that's
actually that I should clarify would
that has a couple meanings right now I
don't mean that people are going
accusing me of being a Russian bot what
I mean is a sort of focus only on Russia
and believe every single story on
uncritically about Russian because I'm
not tell me specifically what I'm wrong
about on the facts regarding what Jill
Stein said and what Jill Stein and her
campaign have or have not done and then
we can have a conversation about that
but don't just riddle me with ad hominem
x' on social media because you don't
like the fact that i'm talking about
this but i do want to hear from you send
me your thoughts i'm on twitter at the
Pakman quick break back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now
have two pairs of Warby Parker offers a
free five day in-home trial of their
glasses you try five pairs you see which
you like I wear contact lenses on the
show but I often wear glasses at night
and on weekends and both of my pairs of
Warby Parker glasses are great I did the
free at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just $95
that's what mine cost to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS